not gonna lie dude I'm gonna say it I'm
[__] sick of getting the hunger jokes
like seven years oh just you know what I
always thought there was a part of me
that was like it's super endearing it's
you know it's very humbling you know
that I look clearly not Japanese and you
know Japanese people are like you know
it validates that oh my Japanese hasn't
fallen off a cliff you know like
considering that I don't actively study
it as much as I used to because I just
don't have as much time anymore yeah but
like it's it's gone to the point now
where like I was in Harajuku a few days
ago with hockey and we were just doing
some shopping or whatever and I think I
got every single store we stopped at
immediately
to me and it's just like I I know
exactly why they're asking that yeah and
and like I don't blame them for it but
it's this now you've just started this
conversation of well why are you so
nihongo josu right yeah tell me why yeah
it's like it's like so so like how did
you study it did you you know how long
have you lived in Japan you know there's
a myriad of questions that it can go
yeah yeah yeah and I've just gotten so
sick of just having to do the same
[__] dialogue options over and over
it's like yeah so my mom's Japanese I
lived here for a while I studied NPC now
yeah it's it's gone but now after all of
the times that I've been in hongo Jose I
figured out the most optimal like
conversation Ender right I just go
thanks
no more that's that's all the info
you're getting because I used to have to
be like yeah my mom's Japanese or you
know like I lived here I studied yeah
yeah now if I just say that's
it they're like oh okay clearly this
person does not want to do yeah you you
chose the secret option rude
yeah yeah just ends the conversation do
you guys still get it often yeah yeah
how do you guys feel towards it I'm sure
with it yeah well you haven't had it as
much also I'm not Japanese as well for
me it's like a it's almost like an open
invitation to kind of speak Japanese and
practice a little bit yeah I'm kind of
chill with it but obviously you don't
need that yeah yeah yeah
um that depends if they're nice or not
if they're annoying I don't know like
granted like every like especially like
store close and stuff like that who ask
it super nice super nice but you know
they're just trying to like have
conversation right yeah you know they're
like genuinely impressed but it's like
now I'm just kind of like I've done my
shopping yeah I mean it's certain people
when they say it and it starts
conversation I'm like oh God yeah
like mainly taxi drivers taxi drivers
here because they're normally really old
yeah they get like really good
conversations or just like you know also
I've never had it in a taxi really yeah
never I find that Japanese taxi drivers
there either like like really talkative
really talkative or just completely
silent yeah you cannot get a word out of
them I don't know maybe I'm just like
getting really lucky or I don't catch
his taxis as often to you guys but like
I always get the taxi drivers that are
just two word answers I got in the cab
today with my parents you know it's
always awkward because you know I if
when there's like four of you and you
know some of the taxi drivers they don't
want people to sit in the front it's
just like a preference thing but it's
like hey there's four of us we gotta sit
in the front of course yeah yeah and so
it's like sometimes they they're like oh
I don't move my stuff and some of them
are like bro some of them they got [__]
everywhere and you're like setting this
one taxi dude was super old definitely
like late 80s yeah 90s
um
and dude I sat down the front seat it
was wet
the [__] I was like oh this is so nasty
sit down dudes dude is so old and he's
like I'll do your Japanese girl like oh
thanks man he's like oh where are you
from me I go I'm the it is like oh
gentleman country
I was like maybe maybe back in your time
he's like he's like
[Music]
saying English words just the most
random [__] he's like those are the best
though yeah I I have out recently where
I was just kind of waiting around in a
store I was looking at some clothes yeah
and this like young Japanese guy like
walks up to me and you know just is like
oh this one very popular
all right I love it I love it and it's
like in Japanese I said back and I'm
like oh yeah I bought some clothes from
here before yeah and then the guy was
obviously thrown back and he's like you
know and then he's just like and but
then afterwards in English he was just
like oh you're Japanese very good I love
this and then and then and then he was
like where are you from and I was like
okay if I say yeah if I say Japan things
are just gonna get complicated so I was
like I'm from Australia in the most
Australian accent possible and he
[__] goes and you know when
foreigners think of Australia right lots
of different things kangaroo boomerangs
whatever right the most stereotypical
[__] a Japanese person can feel this
dude legit goes oh woman basketball
[Music]
yeah I guess we're known for women's
basketball yeah and I was like yeah yeah
woman's basketball all right
so I did not see that coming the old man
in this Taxi
that's some weird [__] he's saying like
I like beer and the whiskey I was like
okay all right thanks man
that'll be
two Yen that's like Nissan yes two Yen
okay all right that's steep discounts
yeah I'll take it but dude this man was
we got a stoplight red lights not even
kidding yeah man pulled out the full
newspaper at the stoplight started
reading the newspaper God damn the whole
windshield reading the newspaper I was
like oh you're gonna help hold it you're
like you're good like what do you see
the lights what are you doing
the lights had changed four minutes ago
and we haven't moved sir genuinely he
just whipped it out I couldn't believe
it I've noticed taxi drivers in Japan by
the way
I would not have any Tokyo no I don't
know because I I a lot of taxi drivers
I've like been with they've they've
always had okay they always have of the
clipboards right do you know what I'm
talking about oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
because okay I figured it out okay what
is that well I think they keep track of
like everyone that's got in their taxi
or something even though the meter
already does this yeah yeah I think it's
like they I'm not sure what they're
clocking but a lot of the taxi drivers
if not all of them they you know even
though you're doing you get paid at this
amount for the journey all of them are
like employed right by a company most of
them I think I'm again I'm not 100 sure
a lot of them are and so that that's not
their pay what you're paying now yeah
their salary so I think they're like
keeping track of something keeping track
of something I don't know yeah I always
thought they were like racially profiles
secret police every time it's just a
secret police officer just tracking your
movements
in case the police come being like did
you see a white male in his 30s getting
your taxis
no because what always confused me is
that I assume they enjoy but keeping
track of like the fair or something but
they never ever do it after you finish
your journey it's always always it's
always mid light sometimes the lights go
and they're still [__] writing and
their hands are off the uh steering wall
and they just [__] go they're like no
I need to finish this racial profile I'm
gonna sit next time just start writing
stuff too I'm anxious and then I close
the book to death now
you just you know if you're sitting in
the front seat just grab just stop
playing tic Tacos yeah your move
yeah but no like uh like I guess it was
like the hunger josu is kind of like
most of the time just like conversation
starter do Japanese people find it as
endearing when we just start speaking I
always do I always do them as well yeah
oh really yeah yeah oh no I do now I've
started doing it everywhere yeah do
Japanese people find it as endearing
when we speak broken ass Japanese be
like ah I think so bearded ah oh dude
Japanese people
they love that [__] even if they don't
it's like I think they prefer it right
like yeah I think I think in in a lot of
minds of Japanese people like
stereotypically I guess like yeah I
think the the general consensus is oh
you're going to the effort to try and
speak to me in the local language and I
think that in and of itself is worth I
guess like the praise or the respect
right because you know it's so easy to
just be like yeah you know what this
weird Japanese language I'm not gonna
learn it my natural language is better
just deal with it kind of thing right
but it's like I think it's the idea of
like oh you know I can only speak
Japanese yeah and you're participating
in speaking Japanese no matter how
broken it is hey you know what new
Hunger [__] josu dog let's go yeah
because I think because there's a lot of
people online are always like man it's
so disrespectful to go to a country and
and not know any of the language it's
like well I mean a lot of Japanese
people don't expect you to no that's
like whether you should or shouldn't it
doesn't really matter it's the
expectations that I think a lot of Asian
countries